fallschirm für das man sehr hohe berge
runter jumpen kann führt dass man
deutsch
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der minecraft crafting ideen wo
ich eure crafting ideen die ich ganz
cool finde wenn sie mal als mod oder in
minecraft gebe vorstelle es war heute
bei uns null grad und wir waren auf dem
weihnachtsmarkt ist erstmal glühwein
geholt und alles und bauer das war so
geil einfach so eine heiße tasse
glühwein in der hand wenn ein handy
zückt in darmstadt wurde 3 ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt am mit der
ersten crafting idee wurde nämlich
zugesendet von nico g und zwar schreibt
er ein schild bestandteile lederriemen
eisen und lederriemen mit aus drei leder
gemacht ich hab das ganze jetzt erstmal
diese lederriemen habe ich jetzt erstmal
wie leder dargestellt ihr seht nämlich
jetzt auch schon das crafting rezept
eingeblendet und zwar sollte man sich
eigentlich mit drei leder die irgendwie
nebeneinander partner kriegt man so
einen lederriemen und diese lederriemen
packt man obendrein als man macht sich
erstmal so einem brustpanzer mehr oder
weniger und packt einfach oben das freie
feld damit man kein eisen muss panzer
bekommt sondern sein schild packt man
dann als und lederriemen reinig platz
ein ganz normales wieder eingepackt weil
ich nicht wusste was genau mit
lederriemen nicht so wirklich gemeint
ist und dann bekommt man diese schild
raus und das ist eigentlich ganz geil
und das wünsche ich mir schon in
minecraft und zwar finde ich das blöd
wenn man das schwert und dann glaubt man
so mit dem schwert so das ist ein
bisschen kacke zwei ganz geil wenn man
noch so eine zweite an hätte man so mit
schildern und so und dass das so rpg
macy und so dass eigentlich ganz cool
und das ist kräftige die nummer eins
lego samurai 10 schreibt mir einen
fallschirm für das man sehr hohe berge
runter jumpen kann führt dass man
jedenfalls schreibt er mir da so ein
paar sachen unserem park crafting
rezepte ich finde allerdings dass ihr
jetzt einfach mal das crafting rezepte
eingeblendet und ich finde das
eigentlich viel cooler also es gibt
schon das teilchen modifikation also
muss ich schon dazusagen habe ich
beispielsweise auch den hintergrund da
genommen wo dieser typ schon mit dem
fallschirm soll moment ihren ist und das
crafting rezept daher finde ich
eigentlich viel besser und zwar einfach
oben drein wolle dann links eine seite
recht seine seiten ein leder einfach so
als sitzt dass man sie einsetzen kann
die fäden so als fäden und oben wolle so
dieser schier mehr oder weniger glaub
ich sage immer sehr oft mehr oder
weniger oder beispielsweise ich bin
irgendwie diese beiden wörter kessel wie
schon ein
nicht mehr leben lang aber schon locker
seit ein paar wochen jedenfalls ist das
ein fallschirm mit dem man wie in gta
beispielsweise wenn man aus einem
flugzeug springen wenn man eine
planespotter am start oder so kann man
mit falschem runterladen oder wenn man
auf dem hohenberg ist und eine schlucht
oder irgendwie sowas kann man darunter
spring fallschirm am start und bekommen
dementsprechend dann keinen fall schaden
an dieser fallschirm benutzt sich
natürlich auch also der ist dann noch
einmal komplett kaputt muss ich nun
machen wenn ich an sich eine richtig
coole sache wenn es hinzugefügt wird und
das crafting idee nummer 2 der letzten
folge habe ich ein bisschen sowas
anmalen geredet mit diesem blattgold und
meinte jetzt jemand zu mir eine
verbesserung und zwar einen pinsel
könnte man ja mal wirklich machen es ist
die farbe es ist der stock ihr seht
jetzt mal das rating jetzt hätte
eingeblendet ganz einfach zwei stärker
darüber die farbe also irgendwie dann
grüne farbstoff blauer farbton pc
beispielsweise bei mir genommen dann
kriege ich so einen weißen pinsel und
damit kann ich dann ganz einfach wenn
ich auf dem blog drauf gucke recht
gedrückt halten dann kann ich den so ein
bisschen anmalen und so ähnlich wie ich
das bei dieser pumpkin modifikation
schon gezeigt hat wo man das mit der
schere so ein gesicht rein ritzen kann
so ähnlich funktioniert es dann auch bei
diesem pinsel einfach rechts gedrückt
halten kannst alle länder dahin anmalen
und das ist jetzt beispielsweise in weiß
halbinsel es gibt ich habe
beispielsweise gesagt aber es gibt doch
noch alle anderen farben die im
hintergrund eingeblendet seht also in
dem hintergrundbild da so ein bisschen
und das war kräftige die nummer drei bei
dir schreibt mir zu vielleicht einen
schlafanzug damit kann man auch am tag
schlaf und seine herzen werden
regeneriert das crafting rezept in
gleich nicht so weh gleichwohl es sie
gibt einen drei von acht rüstungs balken
und jetzt sehen wir mal das crafting
eingeblendet so sieht das ganze aussieht
rechts diese wolle rüstung mehr oder
weniger an der weißen farbe man kann das
ganze allerdings in allen farben bauen
hab ich jetzt einfach mal so wenn man
möchte es gibt ja auch gelbe wolle es
gibt jetzt nicht so was wie gelbes eisen
aber man kann sich natürlich eine
rüstung kann man sich werben aber ich
finde ihn die sonne voller rüstung und
dass man mit der special features
unserer rüstung kann man dann halt am
tag schlaf und die herzen regenerieren
also ich meine wer kennt nicht wenn man
irgendwie tag ist und dann wird auch
dementsprechend dann macht also wenn man
am tag schläft damit dementsprechend
danach auch nachts dass man dann
wirklich so ein bisschen ok kommen ich
bin jetzt mal so man mittags schlafen
dann ist abends und so das ist
eigentlich ganz cool fände ich ganz
interessant und das ist crafting in den
nur
ihr nummer fünf holte mir zugesendet von
lissy und zwar hat sie ein rezept für
straßenlaternen und ich würde sagen die
sind jetzt auch schon das crafting
rezept eingeblendet und zwar eigentlich
ganz simpel wir nehmen einfach rechts
als stil mehr oder weniger zwei
eisenstangen zwei eisen also relativ
robust so als stange dann ein redstone
einfach das ganze muss ja irgendwie so
ein bisschen technik in dick
trainermarkt hat einen klostern weil es
einfach relativ helles und ich weiß
nicht ein könnte theoretisch eine fackel
entpacken habe ich bin bloß dann
eigentlich auch besser dann bekommt man
diese straßenlaterne und dies vier
blöcke wurde ich sagen die hat
vorgeschlagen drei blöcke hoch aber ich
meine selbst diese schon zwei blöcke
hoch drei blöcke bisschen wenig ich
würde sogar sagen so in die fünf blöcke
höher und dann kann man ja einfach
hinsetzen und leitet die da so nach oben
und dann ist seine straßen hat das licht
am start und wer eigentlich ganz cool so
freunde ich hoffe euch hat die folge
kräftige den gefallen es tut mir leid
dass ich hier so ein bisschen verrannt
rum sitze eigentlich habe ich sonst auch
sehr sehr selten caps auf und ich weiß
sie steht mir überhaupt nicht aber es
ist einfach schon wieder ein und 49 ich
bin jetzt wenn ihr das video gerade
sieht bei der deutschen bahn in
frankfurt weil ich den termin hat und
alle jedenfalls würde ich mich freuen
wenn ihr das video mit einer bewertungen
bewertet zeigt mir auf jeden fall immer
ob es euch gefallen hat ob er mehr davon
wollte oder ob es euch nicht gefällt und
wenn ihr eine crafting wird unten damit
in die kommentare dann sehen uns dann
erst mal wieder tun